duane not the rock Johnson is back it's
not an action movie despite what the
marketing campaign for snitch might lead
you to believe this film is clearly a
crying drama with elements of a thriller
at hand with dwayne johnson playing a
compassionate and might i mentioned the
buffest father hollywood has ever seen
how does he do in the role he's
surprisingly effective sure he has his
moments where we're like I was
unbelievable but most of the movie I was
sold on his performance it's definitely
the best role he's done yet and I can
see why they actually cast him for this
film there's also some terrific
supporting work in this movie from Barry
Pepper as a supposedly disturbed DEA
agent Susan Sarandon as a hard-headed
federal prosecutor playing a [ __ ] yet
again but especially Jon Bernthal as an
ex-con who struggles to provide for his
family as far as the film itself goes
it's actually quite good I had
especially low expectations for this
phone so that might be why I'm so
pleasantly surprised but I gotta say the
dramatic moments are felt the reasoning
behind Dwayne Johnson's motivation is
effective their social commentary on the
government stand against the war on
drugs a message that could have been
very much exploited but the film handles
this message very well without being too
preachy about anything the film is
thrilling when it needs to be the world
is believable so the escalating tension
keeps you engaged and concerned for
these characters the basic premise of a
father willing to do anything for his
son is also very moving when I saw the
trailer for this film I wasn't expecting
to be part of an audience I was
applauding when it was all said and done
it seems to me that people who don't
like this movie we're expecting some
type of heavy action drama but it's not
it's a crime drama so I can see why many
people and critics have been let down
but when you take this film on its own
merits it's an effective gritty drum all
in all i gotta say snitch got it right
you
you